I wish that more people realized that if
they had an app idea that they could go
and actually build it themselves that's
why we created the Android basics nano
degree it's a learning path to take
someone from no coding experience to
building a whole portfolio of basic
Android apps I'm fairly certain that
anyone can learn to program for Android
I think everyone comes across that that
moment when they're filling it around
with an app and they're like oh man I
wish it did this the difference is kind
of acting on it it was my opportunity to
no longer have to wish an app existed I
can just make it myself
the biggest reason why I hadn't done it
before was it seemed like such a
daunting task to code I would say I wish
about maybe 14 years ago someone would
have told me that it's something that
anyone can actually learn begin your
journey today by taking the first steps
to becoming an Android developer
you